Parecemos, para informarles,
de que acabamos de suscribir
1 acuerdo con Esquerra republicana de Cataluña,
1 acuerdo para la investidura de Pedro Sánchez
y también
para garantizar la estabilidad de la legislatura
de progreso, que aspiramos a abrir.
Unos acuerdos que tienen 1 característica común,
y es que son mejoras,
mejoras en la convivencia
de la sociedad catalana y por tanto
del conjunto de la sociedad española,
que pretenden pasar página,
abrir 1 nueva etapa
y que también ratifican
1 apuesta Clara por el diálogo y los acuerdos
como la única manera de resolver conflictos,
esencia, de facilitarla,
hacer más habitable en nuestro país.
Incluye,
como saben ustedes, la aprobación de 1 ley de amnistía,
1 ley de amnistía
que devolverá a la política
lo que nunca debió salir de la política
y es 1 ley que todavía se está